asseyez-vous bien et laissez-nous faire notre travail officier
Je suis désolé ce qui se passe pouvez-vous
rester là s'il vous plaît nous essayons de vérifier
ces pétards assurez-vous qu'ils sont bien
propres Je suis désolé ce ne sont pas des
pétards d'accord ces euh  il y a nos
artistes excusez-moi artiste ouais sérieusement
ouais quel genre d'artistes rappeurs et
ils travaillent avec moi en studio en
ce moment voyons le rap n'est pas un
art et je suis désolé qui es-tu je suis le
manager eh bien tu es  perdre votre temps
mr.  le manager doit se moquer de moi tu
perds ton temps vraiment ces clients
sont à toi ces rappeurs ouais ils ressemblent
à des membres de gangs tu ne peux pas venir
ici et arrêter des gens juste à cause de
ce à quoi ils ressemblent tu es fou mais c'est du
harcèlement policier tu as dit  tu étais
manager ouais pas un avocat
c'est important tu ne peux pas venir ici
et arrêter ces gars parce qu'ils sont
noirs